nous voici en plein coeur des
prestigieuses vignes de sancerre qui
réserve bien des surprises oui bien la
surprise
bien des surprises oui et bien des
surprises
la revue millésime du cabaret sont
sirois animée dans les artistes
internationaux est l'une des plus
surprenantes ils m'attendent pour me
raconter leur histoire me transporter
dans leur univers fait de strass et
paillettes alors préparez-vous il
vraiment prévu à être embarqués par la
magie du carat
et
sancerrois
je suis
[Musique]
ça va hein berdos et le taux plein d'air
d'eau était déjà fatigué ça c'est ça
j'avais deux minutes nous on danse deux
heures de spectacle vous pensiez pendant
deux heures exactement vous allez
m'expliquer tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stop stop stop stop
suspects comme le globe il ya
alors alexandre et anastasia ça nous
vient de quel pays cet accent d'avis à
la moldavie et vous vous êtes rencontrés
là-bas oui moi j'étais prof de danse est
un art alizés l'été dans mon école de
danse soit allé depuis le chorégraphe
voilà j'aime composer avec le le
posthume et et la musique moi je suis
danseuse ok je fais
et la magie ça veut dire que c'est moi
qui je me cache de la voie du sort de la
boîte du magicien d'accord comment ça
marche quand on est maman et qu'on est
danseuse de cabaret qu'on bosse au
cabaret travailler ensemble jusqu'à
quatre mois et après les naissances
trois mois après on va revenir sur scène
c'est parti quoi et bien alexandre et
nastasia merci beaucoup mais bon on
revient au cabaret quand même mal de dos
on y est
[Musique]
e
non
mieux
c'est vrai que chanter dans un cabaret
ça ne s'improvise pas comment tu as fait
conservatoire l'école de la rue école de
la stricte une école diary aussi
justement j'ai pris quelques cours de
chant j'ai même eu la chance de prendre
les conversions avec armande altaï car
oui d'accord qui est le public du
cabaret sont sirois et ben on travaille
déjà en premièrement avec les gens de la
région et puis après il ya beaucoup de
monde qui se déplacent ça marche avec le
bouche à oreille la publicité
et puis il ya quand même des artistes de
très bon niveau ici un spectacle
qu'elles sont rythmés dynamique
alexander fait du train un travail
exceptionnel tu as tout dit il et
cabaret sont sirois certes en monde
rural mais avec des artistes de qualité
artistes internationaux à spectacle
grandiose alors c'est parti pour le
final on n'a pas répété on n'est pas
prêt vous vous êtes prêt après mois
[Musique]
voyez du pantalon
magie
[Musique]
lee
non
[Musique]
ils sont tous balle en fête ok
ok